hey what is up guys mkbhd here and if
you'd asked someone at the beginning of
this year what they thought this would
be the year of half of them probably
would have said the year of 4k and the
other half probably would have said
wearables and i already did a video in
early 2014 about the state of 4k and
where that sits right now so i'll have
that linked right below if you haven't
seen that already so might as well now
take a look at where we stand with
wearable tech now this video comes at an
interesting time because of recent
announcements that i'll get to in a
second but i recently did a video on the
top 5 wearable tech and pebble
is the king
for like now for right now obviously
pebble has been very successful since
their breakout kickstarter campaign as a
company and they've established
themselves as pioneers of the smartwatch
they took another step forward with
pebble 2.0 so the new app and the new
watch firmware and they now have pebble
steel so the metal housing and the much
more premium feel and the new wristbands
and they keep the ink display in the app
store and all the stuff that pebble has
been good at they've gotten better at
all of it but even if you're pebble
right now and you've improved on
everything and you locked down your
technology and it's great you still got
to be freaking out at least a little bit
after google's announcements yesterday
that pretty much changed everything
about wearable tech so yesterday google
announced in case you haven't already
heard android wear which is a version of
android designed specifically for
wearables or wearable tech now android
4.4 kitkat as we already know was
designed specifically to have lower
system requirements which will let it
work on lower end devices like
smartphones and also appliances like
refrigerators and even cars but android
wear is designed specifically for
wearable tech
mostly smart watches so before this if
you wanted to build a smart watch you
could do it one of two ways number one
you could build your own operating
system from scratch and a couple of
manufacturers actually did this so we
saw this in the sony smartwatch 2 we saw
this with tizen with some samsung
watches and we saw this with pebble they
built their own os and api from scratch
just to work with the form factor on
your wrist or you could do with the
number two way which is to modify an
existing operating system which in this
case would be android the open source os
and we saw this with the samsung galaxy
gear the first version was a modified
version of android very heavily modified
but they had to take that existing os
and change it up now watching all the
videos and promo material for android
wear it's clear that this was designed
with the smaller display in mind it's
designed to be on your wrist it's
designed to be glanceable information
swipeable interface it's very pretty
nice and clean elegant and it's got a
whole lot of information at your
fingertips and also a whole lot of
integration with google now we were
waiting to see something like this
sooner or later from google even though
we didn't exactly know what it would
look like so now that we have this new
version of android wear when are we
going to start seeing devices that use
it so motorola and lg are going to be
launch partners uh but in very different
ways so lg i guess being the less
interesting
of the two it's going to be building a
more traditional smartwatch style square
display smartwatch just with android
wear instead of a modified or custom os
and it's going to be a lower-end
smartwatch probably with a lower price
tag and less features but the much more
interesting launch partner which i think
a lot of us are eyeing right now is
motorola and their moto 360 smartwatch
this is the round smartwatch that google
showed in the android wear promo video
and it's something to be a lot more
proud of so this is an absolutely
beautiful looking smart watch i mean
this thing is insta by territory for me
right now i cannot wait to get my hands
on hardware like this it's beautifully
designed it has some great looking watch
faces and it makes really all the right
design decisions uh to look like a
regular watch the pebble does not look
like a regular watch it's a rectangle
and you can do your best with watch
faces to make it look more elegant and
make it look a little bit more like a
regular watch but no matter what you do
you're not going to be fooling anyone
into thinking that that's a traditional
watch and that matters to a lot of
people the moto 360 is honestly a work
of art at this point to do what it does
and i'm not seeing any weird charging
ports or batteries or cameras or
anything unnecessary it does its best to
look the part of a really nice watch and
i'm sure the price tag will reflect that
when it's released this summer but i
have my eye on that for sure now the
only thing i'm actually concerned about
here with these new watches is the fact
that they have lcd displays there's a
reason why a lot of smart watches have
gone with e-ink displays recently it's
because that's a much more natural
feeling technology it's like looking at
paper almost and that also gives you the
ability to have much longer battery life
and constant on watches so if you want
to check the time really quick all you
have to do is look at it and it's
already there you don't have to shake it
to get it to appear or do some sort of
fancy gesture to get the lcd to turn on
that doesn't feel very natural very
watch-like so if moto 360 can nail down
outdoor visibility
battery life
and convenience for checking the time so
it doesn't feel unnatural
you can have all my money also android
wear is still android so it's still the
open source os so it'll likely be able
to talk to any android smartphone uh
unlike some of the other modded android
watches which would only really talk to
a very small number of devices so if you
have a device that's not a galaxy device
if you have a nexus or a moto x or
whatever android device you have maybe
even an ios or windows phone device in
the future you'll probably be able to
use this new watch and also can we talk
about the fact that this watch is a
circle not a square like every literally
every other smart watch ever has been a
square that's why we thought flexible
displays were the answer to making these
rectangular things less bulky on our
wrists we thought we had to curve them
around our risk but really i'm excited
to see what developers do with a circle
now that we have a circular display i
mean where else do you see circular lcds
out there so i'm excited to see what
developers do with this sdk making their
apps play with that correctly that odd
resolution and viewable area on it but
ultimately this is the first circular
display that i'm actually decided to be
excited about so there you go that's
android wear and now we know exactly
what the future of wearables at least
smart watches are gonna look like and
it's looking pretty dope not gonna lie
uh apple i hope you took notes so i'm
keeping an eye on apple i'm keeping an
eye on motorola i'm keeping an eye on lg
keeping an eye on pebble
keeping an eye on google i o
nexus smartwatch combo anyone that would
be nice uh keeping an eye on all the
other guys who are making smart watches
before this with modded versions of
android because if we can go from this
to
this in three months imagine where we'll
be in three or four more uh so that's
pretty exciting stuff to think about
either way thanks for watching catch you
next time
later
peace
you